this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by movement we get it
holiday shopping can be tough but thanks
to movement all that gift-giving anxiety
can disappear with it with the press of
a button these watches make the perfect
purchase for just about anyone in your
life guy or girl and remember they only
start at $95 it's a good it's a good
thing to get for the holidays get 15%
off today with free shipping and free
returns by going to MVM t.com slash
Congrats this episode 45 is also brought
to you by the cash app it seems that all
of my cult following here at this cult
and all the babies are switching to the
cash app as it is the number one finance
app in the App Store they've introduced
the cash cart a new black debit card
that you can design yourself via the app
allowing you to use the cash that you
keep in the app anywhere you want plus
it's the best way to pay people back
download the free cash app for iOS or
Android now 45 that's right
so next episode there will be more
episodes than there have been presidents
do you understand what that means that's
a great deal I didn't know we were ever
gonna get to Abe Lincoln we're gonna
pass pumpkin Donald Trump dude so we got
we got it going babies we really got it
going babies and this is the patriotic
this is patriotic very patriotic of us
to do 46 episodes next week makes no
sense but however anyway
let's see first let's get some business
fresh out the way dude you guys we are
stocking restocking and restocking the
merch [ __ ] the store on Chris D'Elia
calm and you can go get all your podcast
wearables and you get the freakin shirt
because let's face it it is free conch
and you can get the know CUDA T you can
get the e CUDA you can get the
congratulations t-shirt which is a
[ __ ] sharp blue looks really good on
tan [ __ ] and really good on
pasty white people too you got blue eyes
you got blue eyes get blue shirt if you
got blue eyes and you don't wear blue
shirts you're really hurting your
attractiveness level game but we got
true baby tees we've also got the
crystal Lea metal tee which basically is
my face with a skull on it with but it
would basically just looks more me than
I actually look because I look like a
skeleton yeah some pictures you ever see
some pictures of yourself where you're
just like oh [ __ ] that's how I look I
saw a picture of me sometimes I got this
I do a smile I smile so much that I get
like I actually for a 37 year old man
mice I'm gonna just come out right out
and [ __ ] say it my skin looks good
dude I don't really have that many
wrinkles I'm [ __ ] maybe because I
used my face a lot but sometimes when I
do certain faces the ship bunches up
around my eyes and all of a sudden I
look like I died a week ago but uh yeah
there were certain shots in my special I
don't remember what special it was I
think it was my first one actually I was
33 that where I just looked like
Skeletor with mentioning my first
special black or white male black comic
a lot of you guys have seen incorrigible
and mm man on fire because it's
streaming but you can watch the man on
the white male black comic which is my
first batch
which has the drunk girls bid on it and
all that [ __ ] you can see that uncommon
Comedy Central app and or you know maybe
can get on YouTube I have no [ __ ]
idea but that special that I did my
first special will be four years ago
four years ago today if you're listening
to this on Friday December 6 the
December 6th
four years ago it came out and that's
crazy to me because uh it seems like so
much longer than you then so much longer
ago I mean I I did to think that I've
done three specials in four years is
just weird to me maybe that's wrong but
that's what Facebook said it popped up
in my memories and we know one thing
that Facebook literally never lies you
can't it doesn't lie hey Mark Zuckerberg
was that a real thing where it said he
was gonna start taking classes to seem
more human that's gotta be fake
I saw a headline it was like Mark
Zuckerberg is is talking to
psychologists and he's gonna take
classes how to appeal more he appear
more human hey man if you're doing that
I swear my producer Google's the
wrongest [ __ ] he write this is how he
Google's that what I just said
Zuckerberg classes it's not gonna come
up does it not say it must have been
[ __ ] because somebody was like
that's exactly what an alien would do
and of course it is exactly what an
alien would do or a robot he really does
seem like a robot is odd but I don't say
that because I don't want my facebook
information getting all hacked up and
[ __ ] so um so yeah so you can watch all
my stuff and get [ __ ] and gets it good
to get for the holidays too man if you
know somebody's a listener for the
podcast just go to Chris D'Elia calm and
go go ahead and get them a true baby tee
it's the neck it's a very close it's
it's a way to emulate an elder doesn't
mean you're an elder but the pins we
sell I'm sorry we don't sell we give
away the elders are the ones on the
actual or the adults like the same thing
it looks like a pin a little bit you
cheating a little bit but anyway yeah me
yeah Mew Layton though yeah Mew late
frickin do it but yeah Mew Layton I was
in Irvine this past weekend and I did
eight shows way way too many I felt sick
after every show cuz was drained up you
ever get that sick or your you ever get
not sick you're not sick but you're like
run down you're like man I feel sick
sometimes I get so tired I feel sick do
you guys get that way too I don't know
but I I was in Irvine I did eight shows
and you know Irvine I'll tell you what
Irvine is a toss-up you never know what
kind of crowd you're gonna get sometimes
you're gonna get got people who want to
come to the show real fans and sometimes
you're gonna get that dirty OC piece of
[ __ ] type person that have like that are
like just like cater to my every need
bro you know like I'm out man this is my
night man what I paid [ __ ] $35 for a
ticket I don't get [ __ ] waited on
hand and foot
dude I I kicked out one time I think was
two times ago I was there 60 people
because it was a huge birthday party
because they were being so obnoxious and
I went online and I've told this story
countless times I told her on an AOL
interview and these every time I tell
this story people pop up from the peep
from the [ __ ] show and they say do
you think you could kick us out we
walked out we're full they're so [ __ ]
like they're like we're with full force
man you tried to kick out two of us but
we all went as a team cuz it's [ __ ] it
like dude shut up shut up I can't stand
what people act like war is happening
when war is not happening you know what
I'm talking about
those people who are like dude you [ __ ]
with one of us that's such an OC
mentality you [ __ ] with one of us you
[ __ ] with the fam know you don't know
you don't hate you work at Verizon okay
dude stop acting like you're in hae-jin
a battalion dude you general you
lieutenant
Hey
janna battalion do you go overseas and
fight for America or do you work at
Verizon hey dude you know what real
quick
shut the [ __ ] up and get me a Mophie
charger oh cool man
you have [ __ ] death before dishonor
tattooed on your collarbone oh nice Hey
Dude what's up with those phone plans
you know these guys like you don't work
at a [ __ ] kiosk at the mall death
before dishonor right who the [ __ ] you I
saw a guy the other day I was outside of
a gym he was talking soul at first of
all he had no shirt on and he had his
shirt tucked into his pants hanging over
his shorts bro you're not in [ __ ]
what's that band crazytown you're my
butterfly sugar honey you're not the
[ __ ] you're not in crazy town hey
dude you ain't [ __ ] a little is some
41 no put your [ __ ] shirt on okay so
this guy uh this guy [ __ ] puts puts
he's talking on the phone so I don't
even know how to he's got two guns on
his back okay
two tattoo guns on his back shoulders
and they're pointing to his head okay
you listening to me they're pointing to
his [ __ ] head on his back shoulders
so it looks like his head's getting
[ __ ] blasted off all right and I
don't know if that was intentional or
not just pretend it's intentional
because I can't I can't act like this
guy [ __ ] didn't know that he was
doing that all right it said something
in between the guns probably death
before dishonor
okay he had no shirt on walking around a
parking lot talking so loud business on
the phone but he had Bluetooth speaker
he had Bluetooth he had a beat
beats on and he was just holding the
phone talking like this on his beats
dude
hey man no alright put your shirt on or
join some 41 and don't [ __ ] do
bluetooth talking with your beats
headphones on what do you need what are
you talking to you talk unless you're
talking to dr. Dre you talking to Dre
are you talking to another guy with
[ __ ] stars on his shoulders or two or
birds
you know those [ __ ] hummingbirds that
people have what is it that [ __ ] takes
off like that I don't get it like
everyone thinks they're [ __ ] who is
that guy the good-looking guy who had
like a moment in like 99 that did up he
was like a punk song guy and now he like
hosts extra you know I'm talking about
I just small on a flyer it wasn't that
guy put your arms around me baby mark
McGrath yeah mark McGrath dude yeah look
mark McGrath dude chicks loved him when
look at him you know and now he just
hosts to extra what is he did he got
some work done huh for sure that's so
[ __ ] yeah and he does he has the
hummingbird shits on his on his arms but
that's the thing man I don't understand
like he had low he had hummingbirds on
like imagine getting because guys got
that after he got that like imagine
getting hummingbirds after mark McGrath
got them and you're not mark McGrath
like God he was on the
cover of Rolling Stone it's amazing how
[ __ ] changes and now he's like now he's
like Will Smith and a little bit of a
truck a little bit of trouble [ __ ]
dude I cannot watch those shows without
getting actually depressed Miley Cyrus
got herself in a little bit of heat
today you know
turns out Sam Rockwell is a little bit
is underwater
so looks like [ __ ] who Li came to
think of a person literally Jada
pinkett-smith dress was a turtle
Luke is a [ __ ] I can't believe people
watch that [ __ ]
extra extra Brown and then and then
it'll always be some guy every time they
get a new host it's some guy that you
haven't seen in 12 years you're like oh
[ __ ] the only guy that [ __ ] nailed it
and and and [ __ ] dude you know how
hard this is let me just explain to you
something about Mario Lopez this guy is
the [ __ ] okay this guy is a
[ __ ] is do you understand how
hard what Mario Lopez did was he went
from one of dude the guy's attitude is
the [ __ ] here's the deal man
he was AC Slater and for those young
[ __ ] out there you don't know
Saved by the Bell say by the Bell was
one of the biggest shows for kids for us
when we were young all right Mario Lopez
was AC Slater on this show now he was
the character was awesome he was like
the football jock type guy and all the
girls liked him and he was a ladies man
and he [ __ ] killed it on the show
okay there was screech on that show and
then the other guys Zack Morris and
screech basically I think blegh did a
porn and learned karate that's how he
was trying to [ __ ] come back right
screech did a porn and learn karate all
right now the Zack Morris is whose name
is escaping me and I know the guy which
is [ __ ] pieces
mark-paul Gosselaar right great the
nicest guy he's had a career uh he was
on that show the baseball show that's
out now that which is supposedly
actually pretty [ __ ] good I don't
watch it but that girl who's on is like
beautiful we're supposed to like believe
that this [ __ ] gorgeous girl's good
at baseball and I don't even mean that
gorgeous girls can't be good at baseball
but you know it's it's real hard to find
a really gorgeous gorgeous girl that
would here's the thing if I was a
gorgeous girl I would just [ __ ] you
could get anything you want in life you
don't have to do anything you don't have
to develop a personality because guys
are pieces [ __ ] and they'll just
literally [ __ ] cater to your every
move so if you're a gorgeous girl and
you excel at something it's even harder
congratulations you did it because you
developed the personality even though
you didn't have those girls deserve a
medal
those girls deserve everything they want
because they [ __ ] you know girls talk
about oh you know some girls talking
about I was bullied because of my body
because I'm not you know a model and
this and that but dude if you're a model
and also you didn't use that but really
you got [ __ ] you made some [ __ ]
happen with your life and didn't just be
like okay [ __ ] it I'll just have guys
Google me but anyway mark-paul Gosselaar
isn't a show but what what uh what uh
Mario Lopez did was became an a host on
extra and now this guy is so everywhere
and he has branded himself and people
don't even think of him as AC Slater
anymore and that is the hardest thing to
do in Hollywood I think if you become
known as something I look at Steve Urkel
no matter what the [ __ ] he's done is
just Steve Urkel and he's tried but
Mario Lopez has overcome the [ __ ]
insurmountable odds and he's [ __ ]
become Mario Lopez not AC Slater and
that dude is the [ __ ]
what he's done is one of the hardest
things and I commend Mario Lopez and
also I follow him on Instagram and I
love following him in on Instagram and
also he's like what is he 42 and his
body and he's got like seven kids has
this guy do it he's incredible man
uh but anyway I don't know what I was
talking about oh yeah
Irvine so I was in Irvine and oh yeah so
you never know what the [ __ ] show is
they're gonna you're gonna get gig and
get the piece of [ __ ]
trash OC or you're gonna get the the
people who are like really like
well-behaved and nice I mean cuz osseous
is awesome and Orange County is is uh
you know it's definitely cliquish and a
lot of like rich white people probably a
lot of racists but and a lot of like
privileged [ __ ] but also they
have like really smart Asians and [ __ ]
and like zero black people like I don't
know like I never see black people in
Orange County but oh and they do have
like Latino type like Mexicans and [ __ ]
but they I did shows and I had a lot of
really good shows oh so I kicked 60
people out yeah that was [ __ ] years
ago
but so then this these crowds were good
they have we had some chatter
[ __ ] when I open or shut him
down and they were good for the rest of
the time I was on stage but then there
was one chick one show that just kept
going yeah like that was her [ __ ]
like don't do that I understand you're a
fan but laughs here's the Heuer the
things you do if you're at a comedy show
you laugh or you don't laugh that's it
you cry or you laugh let's pretend you
eat at a comedy show a library that's
what happens don't need to go that's so
annoying
that's so [ __ ] annoying and now again
so free conch but you being piece of
[ __ ] don't
don't do what are you laughing at me
WOM fire I love when he laughs man
because it makes me feel like cuz he's
dead these guys are my only audience you
know one fire one and wanna fire two
I need to get them two shirts with the
things with the thing one and thing two
you know yeah
dude when I was a kid I there were
shirts there was a shirt I wanted like
that I'm with stupid and it had a
[ __ ] arrow to the left and I thought
that was the funniest [ __ ] ever you know
to just walk with somebody and have them
be the on the left and you're walking
with I'm with stupid it's you know what
dude I got to get a shirt like that man
I'm with stupid with an arrow to the
left and just [ __ ] make sure it
wherever you walk with is on your left
you know what kind of [ __ ] boss [ __ ]
that is man that's some cool dad [ __ ]
but I'll tell you what
that's some [ __ ] awesome [ __ ] I'm
with stupid with an arrow to your left
dude you got to get that shirt and then
make sure nobody's ever on your [ __ ]
right
nobody's ever on your [ __ ] right by
the way last remember last episode I did
I was singing system of it down dude
I've been listening to system of a down
for [ __ ] all week we listened to it
on the way to Irvine and I got an opener
and his name's Craig and he has really
long hair and he looks literally looks
like a guy that would only do weed all
day only smoke weed and eat weed
brownies and do [ __ ] mushrooms and
he's sober it's completely sober and he
wears a Trader Joe's hat I hang out with
cartoons I [ __ ] hang out with
cartoons he has long hair and his face
kind of looks like Maz Jobrani
undercover and he's this white he's
white he's my his dad's white and his
mom's Mexican and he has a Trader Joe's
hat always he works at Trader Joe's
always wears flannel shirts and then
[ __ ] vans and in tongues like this
and he's just like oh I love a system of
it down and when he laughs he laughs
like this
and then and then we were we were we
were doing this thing on the way to
Irvine we were freestyling like Joe
freestyling obviously not for real I
hate by the way when when I know it's a
little bit of a racist thing but I can't
stand when white guys freestyle for real
unless they actually grew up in the
culture so it's not really racist but
like well like when guys who just have
like middle-class families that are just
like that listen to [ __ ] Kanye West
and [ __ ]
freestyle when they were in like polo
tees you know oh I want to [ __ ] and
they do it for real though you know and
they start rapping about the streets
like what's more cringy than that but I
like to freestyle and when I freestyle
first of all I don't rhyme dude that
[ __ ] is for [ __ ] man I don't [ __ ]
rhyme cuz here's the deal man if you're
a rapper all these rappers are like yeah
I'm [ __ ] I'll blast your face
off I'll kill you [ __ ] you ain't
[ __ ] I'll murder everything moving hey
you know what you do for a living
rhyme that's the least hardcore thing of
all time rhyming dude you rhyme yeah but
let me stack these ones and these guns
you just rhymed
are you [ __ ] dr. suit you're
basically dr. Seuss dude you dr. Dre are
you dr. Seuss I grew up on these mean
streets really stop rhyming dude I mean
unbelievable and and so but when these
[ __ ] white guys with like frosted
tips like mark McGrath style
[ __ ] are like yeah you don't
[ __ ] with me I got my crew when the chit
pipa papa be nah don't you don't got
[ __ ] man
you play lacrosse you know you [ __ ]
have done you you've literally played
with a Ouija board you know how [ __ ]
white it is to play with a Ouija board i
guarante I bet I'd go on record to tell
you 0 other races have ever played with
a Ouija board
unless you get like the funky alt black
girl that's done it you know but she's
been with a bunch of white guy white
white girls that has done it like dude
Ouija boards you know the two whitest
things of all time
Ouija boards and escape rooms right I
said this before on the podcast never
it's the whitest thing to be like oh
let's pretend we're trapped in a room
and then it's also the whitest thing
ever to be like ooh let's see what the
what the what the [ __ ] dark world is
saying unless you're a black chick with
purple lipstick on a black with purple
lipstick is the number one which crafty
person except for pasty white chicks
with black lipstick but anyway we
freestyled on the way there but we don't
you don't rhyme dude that shit's for
[ __ ] [ __ ] man and you don't talk
about guns man you start rapping about
how you [ __ ] like I was divorced and
I probably ruined a girl's life for a
little bit during the beat that's
hardcore man
I had a two-year marriage we barely had
sex at the end of it that's hardcore
[ __ ] bro you don't talk about [ __ ]
the streets or or the streets are real
bro I went there I went to therapy after
I dropped out of college I went every
week and sometimes I cry during it and
don't rhyme bro I'm [ __ ] harder than
you [ __ ] that's rhyming don't
buy a
you know half of these rappers are like
oh I gotta buy a gun cuz I started
rapping about it what that's backwards I
used to have a buddy turned out to be a
piece of [ __ ] but he he what did he do
he started wearing the nicotine patch
first and then got addicted to it and
then started smoking idiot
one fire no so I'm talking about [ __ ]
idiot you know these rappers have start
rapping about guns and then buy the gun
that doesn't count bro you got to start
with the guns and then rap about the
life now I'm talking of course it's
happened before of course it's happened
before
it's happened a lot a lot of these guys
like jay-z sold coke or crack or
whatever the [ __ ] okay you know man how
about a rappers that have sold crack one
time and then I've been like I dog now
now I'm legit you know that's happened
you know that's happened yo I saw crack
man I did [ __ ] Tom did [ __ ] three
days in a dunk tank in a [ __ ] tank
and what do you call it the dunk tank
now I call it the what the drunk the
[ __ ] they call it anyway whatever it's
not a drunk tank because I'm mixing [ __ ]
up the dunk tank I've done a dunk tank
before well they're not Saturday we know
I think I actually have I don't know
anyway hey guys me on DS every year
millions of people receive the lat the
least like gift of all time and that's
underwear right that's like your aunt
gets it for you oh my god thank you but
we still give it to our family and our
loved ones who just don't want it but
maybe it's not the underwear that that's
the problem it's the kind of underwear
right your aunt's not gonna get you this
stuff but she should me undies the only
underwear that makes her an amazing gift
now let me tell you something I have me
on DS I really literally only wear me on
these it's the only underwear I have
everybody I talked to we're Joe Rogan
all these guys they wear me on these
it's the best
flexible soft waistband it's three times
softer than cotton I tell people to get
it they get it and they thank me it's
the truth
and they have cool designs they always
come out with new design
the designs they have now are really
cool I saw one that says have a nice day
on it that'd be cool to have I want to
get those but the perfect gift that
everyone is gonna love you for because
everyone's gonna wear underwear anyway
so make them wear me undies you got it
don't give underwear it give me on these
this holiday season to get your
exclusive 20% off the softest underwear
and socks you will ever wear free
shipping and 100% satisfaction guarantee
go to my undies comm / Congrats that's
me on DS dot-com / Congrats movement now
you've heard me talk about movement and
I'm sure you got yourself a watch now
let's finish your holiday shopping and
get a movement watch for someone on your
list if someone likes watches or even if
they don't movement starts at just 95
dollars at a department store you're
looking at 400 to 500 bucks that's too
much man you can really save and get
cool gifts with these movement watches
they figured out a way that by selling
online they were able to cut out the
middleman and retail markup providing
the best possible price
it's got classic design design movement
watches are sleek they're very cool with
a minimalist design over they've sold
over 1 million watches in 160 countries
I have a watch it's very cool I chose
the gold this gold one it's very sleek I
look like boss I'm gonna wear it with my
shirt that says I'm with stupid and
points to someone to the left that
doesn't have a movement watch 50% off
today free shipping and free returns by
going to MVM t.com slash Congrats now is
the time to step up your watch game
that's MVM t.com slash Congrats join the
movement so yeah that's that's what's up
man I even I don't even even looked at
more my my uh my buddy how about my
buddy this I've talked about this I
talked this I talked about this probably
in like episode five or something about
how people who spend time with you
should know who you are
almost drooled right there by the way
when I said who you are but dude I
by the way we ever talk in drool I do
that I've done that I don't remember
last time I've done it probably eight
months ago well I'm a 37 year old man so
it doesn't get so passionate that I
drool and guess what dude I don't that's
how it should be
dude if you don't drool a little bit
when you talk you if you don't drool
every now and then when you talk you
ain't [ __ ] that's it that's it if you're
checking your mouth while you're talking
you ain't [ __ ] lose control baby lose
control when you're passionate you're
talking about some [ __ ] you're talking
about your job lose control drool a
little bit I do it guess what guess what
sometimes when I have sometimes when I
make love I drool if you're checking
your own mouth when you make love and
you're thinking about oh [ __ ] I can't I
gotta [ __ ] keep my mouth closed so I
don't drool you are not making love
focus on nothing while you're making
love don't focus on the girl
don't focus on you you focus on [ __ ]
nothing bro you focus on nothing or
you're not making love you know where
you are when you make love elsewhere or
you're not making love all this [ __ ]
about Oh pay attention to your partner
pay attention to the can if you're not
focusing on elsewhere you never made
love be blissful be [ __ ] out to lunch
[ __ ] all this [ __ ] man
if you're trying to please the girl you
ain't doing [ __ ] you ain't doing [ __ ]
when you're in it you're in it right
when you're playing baseball
you're not I gotta [ __ ] get all the
technical [ __ ] right I gotta this and
that you're loosey-goosey you're hitting
homeruns you're [ __ ] shagging fly
balls you're loosey-goosey man Willie
Mays dude caught the ball with his bare
hand he didn't try to it was there and
it was easier he did it he was
loosey-goosey and at that moment that
was the drool of baseball that was the
drool of baseball if you're talking and
you don't drool once every eight months
you ain't saying [ __ ] and if you make
love and you don't drool every other
time every third time you [ __ ] don't
make love you know what you're doing
you're [ __ ] at the partner that's
what you're doing you might as well go
in and out and get a burger you're not
[ __ ] experienced in experiencing the
restaurant you're not experiencing the
[ __ ] when people say oh yeah let's
go to a steak house [ __ ] you dude no
it's not about going to a steak house
and getting a steak it's about feeling
where you're trying to end it's about
the moment dude that's why I don't make
plans that's what I'll [ __ ] make
plans
hey yeah [ __ ] Friday let's go to that
steak house Friday comes along I don't
want steak then what you got to go to a
steak house
you're not making love to the [ __ ]
situation man go to the place that makes
you drool baby
I've [ __ ] him sure I lost a lot of
the people when I'm talking about this
but you guys who I lost I don't want you
in my cult anyway if the girl looks back
when you drool making love and she's
like what the [ __ ] Uber's outside if she
looks back at you if she likes it I got
a new [ __ ] roommate you ain't going
anywhere unless you want to but you
don't step it up dudes its 2018 coming
up drool more I'm serious too I'm I'm a
hundred percent serious you think drool
hasn't come out of my mouth while I was
onstage take a [ __ ] hike cuz that's
what I do that sir I love that that's my
love you ever see [ __ ] Leonardo
DiCaprio act in Basketball Diaries snoc
comes out of his [ __ ] nose yes a
little too much but at least he was in
it you got to get to that point where
[ __ ] snots coming out of your nose
man was you ain't [ __ ] you ain't [ __ ]
any of these Wall Street [ __ ]
you think snots come out of their nose
I'm business dude if I was on the
trading room floor
and I was like sell it buy it look at
the stocks get it going up down check
the Dow you better believe it that's my
life's passion I got snot I got drool I
I got it I got it and I'm making money
dude I'm stacking gouda and we're
backing up the Brinks truck while I'm a
mess and I got a [ __ ] I'm with stupid
tie on cuz god dress up and it's
pointing to the guy who's dry as [ __ ]
doing it for a job this is my passion
let me stack the monster with the drooly
tie I'm stacking monster with a drooly
tie bro you [ __ ]
bitch-ass Cudas piles are drooling my
cult at the lock log cabin we don't go
outside we got to grow these plants let
the drool hit the ground let the plants
[ __ ] blossom up
that's our garden this [ __ ] is real life
babies one of my dogs is in the corner
looking at me and one of my dogs is
literally putting his face up against
something like he's like I don't know
what's happening like he you know what
my dog looks like right now the end of
the Blair Witch Project when the guys
[ __ ] standing in the corner and you
know it's because the [ __ ] person
made him do that or whatever the [ __ ]
when I saw Blair Witch Project bro I
couldn't see for [ __ ] a week I don't
know what I was talking about drooling
before that let's talk about something
man I don't remember I went off on a
tangent this is what happens though we
are you know what I hope I hope I hope
you guys were listening to that part of
the podcast with your parents cuz they
need to know cuz you know who's never
drooling parents right oh my they would
go like that oh my oh my my dogs are
kissing now I turned them on yeah so I'm
gonna do these other ads yeah hey guys
I'll talk to you some about something
that's a little bit new in my life here
it's really hard to pick out the perfect
gift but all too easy to get it totally
wrong man crates calm the surest way to
find gifts that guys will actually love
guaranteed it's not a cheese of the
Month Club or a new tie which is very
weird that I'm saying that now because I
was just talking about ties and cheeses
man crates offers over 100 hand curated
gift collections for every type of guy
from the rugged outdoorsman to the
sports fanatic and everything in between
like the whiskey appreciation crate with
a personalized decanter in glasses for
his favorite drink or the grillmaster
crate with a brass knuckle meat
tenderizer and a cast-iron smoker box
hey you manly you get this go to grande
mates doc go to man crates calm my
grande mates with my foghorn leghorn go
to man crates calm pick the perfect
crate and choose the delivery date crate
arrives he gets to pry that bad boy open
with his own laser engraved crowbar both
men's health and Allure magazine are
saying man crates are the perfect gift
to men and those who those two don't
agree on anything so on the holidays
with this huh go to man crates calm /
Congrats and get 5 percent off your
order that's five percent off man crates
dot-com / congrats man crates calm /
congrats square cash
one of the favorites babies and all of
the babies are switch it to the cash app
and it's the number one finance app in
the App Store maybe it's because it's
the best way to pay people back I do it
friends family co-workers even kudus
sending and receiving money is totally
free and fast payments can be deposited
directly in your bank account in seconds
here's how it works you download the
square cash app you link your debit or
credit card and you put in an email
address and complete a payment you know
how it works
they'll get a notification they receive
the money that's it no gimmicks you
don't get listed in a feed I hate when
you use the other guys and they list it
it'll feed hey you paid Tom for throw
pillows and now you know everyone
everyone knows you're buying throw
pillows I don't want people knowing my
bed game the cash card is very cool for
this Square cash thing it's a new black
debit card that you can design yourself
via the app the cash card allows you to
use the cash that you keep in an app
anywhere you want you'll get
notifications for all payments paid made
with the card directly via the cash app
laser at your card and personalize it
and it'll be delivered directly to you
for free and so some of these guys send
me their cards pictures of their cards
some of them one of them had a kuda a
barracuda on it with a no cooter sign on
it it was very cool very very poorly
drawn but thanks for trying whoever sent
me that the cash app team is constantly
building awesome new features so what
are you doing using the other guys
this cash out today download the free
cash app for iOS or Android now that's
what I was talking about Craig my buddy
went on Imus and he was uh he was like
we were listening to singing that oh and
we were talking that's what we were
doing we were talking about freestyling
that's how we do it man don't rhyme um
yeah you're not hardcore if you don't
rock you're not hardcore if you rhyme is
what I was trying to say is we're always
trying to say um took three guys to
Irvine Craig mark and Mike and our mark
is my Irish buddy whenever you tell him
something he says or seriously it's so
[ __ ] annoying or seriously yeah man
I'm [ __ ] saying it that's why I'm
saying it hey you know I had a good show
and [ __ ] in San Francisco Oh
seriously it's a good crowd yeah yeah
man dude I used a that was like my first
pet peeve I used to know this guy named
Derek Yee in high school and I would
always [ __ ] he would always be like
that was my first pet peeve I think that
really started grinding my gears I was
like the inception of this [ __ ]
podcast right there Derek E I would say
hey there's basketball practice after
school and you'd be like oh there is and
then I'd have to be like yeah what are
we doing here what we doing here we
already [ __ ] I'd said it oh cool
that's what you say oh there is yeah
butters shut the [ __ ] up
I mean butters is trying to get one fire
to [ __ ] pet him and he's my little
italy-- one fires like this like he's on
the cover of [ __ ] Kazaam come here
cuz he knows last time he was like
[ __ ] hey and he could just stop stop
stop in the [ __ ] ass [ __ ] with a car
and he's literally looks like Shaq and
Kazaam like this come here
come up here Bubba come on buddy might
one of my dogs hops so hi
they're brothers the other one thinks it
can't but he can't don't be a bitch-ass
come up here come up here come here
Bubba come on I gotta do it you can do
it dude he's got a sweater on like a
little [ __ ] come here yeah dude you got
a sweater on like you're a [ __ ]
rapist huh you're a sweat like you're a
[ __ ] date rapist how much did a breed
a rapist wear sweaters right [ __ ]
offsets it come here come here buddy
it's got a skull on it never trust a guy
with like a [ __ ] you know what I mean
argyle sweater or like a or like a never
going if you want a date with a guy with
a cashmere sweater guard your [ __ ]
drink that's all I'm saying guys trying
to [ __ ] hide something put on a
t-shirt or a button-down and you're good
you got to be on a date with a guy with
a cashmere sweater be the [ __ ] careful
man be the [ __ ] careful I'm telling you
especially weeds like clean shaven yeah
azar chin uh dude I've been [ __ ]
going nuts with my shoes
I've been bar I've been getting sneakers
I'm such an idiot dude I just don't I
don't have like I'm like I'm not I'm not
I don't have a family you know what I
mean so I don't have like to put my kids
through school I don't have kids and
[ __ ] so like I just can buy shoes you
know and I'm just an idiot man I love
shoes it's weird it's weird it's very
weird it's not even like I got the I got
the easies I got those semi-frozen
Easy's and I got those I just ordered
the [ __ ] blue tint Easy's and then I
got the I got these ultra boosts and I
got there I just love Jordans I'm such a
[ __ ] [ __ ] I'm such a [ __ ] and I
post these uh these these fashion photos
on my Instagram like as a joke about how
I'm a fashion blogger and some people
think it's real and it's just like how
dumb can you be
like how dumb can you [ __ ] be to look
at a comedians page and think anything
but oh this is a joke you know why it's
because of [ __ ] comedians that post
dramatic [ __ ] on their instagrams oh it
drives me nuts man every now and then
it's fine but some of these some
comedians out there are like I have
great friends and this and that and
couldn't get through you what do you
what are you doing what's your brand hey
what's your brand what's your [ __ ]
brand dude what are you doing people
coming to you for comedy
I mean it's cool like it's cool to
expand your brand like what Kevin Hart
is doing is cool he's he's in he's
obviously very funny but he also uses
his Instagram to try and like brand
himself as a fitness guy because of
health and he's trying to inspire people
and that's [ __ ] cool that's good I
like that um but some of these guys just
like or lost online you know and not
just comedians I feel like this is a
common theme in congratulations but I
mean man I saw a [ __ ] girl the other
day I put it I put it in my I don't know
if it'll be like I put I put this thing
up on the like like what is this this
could be the most [ __ ] up Instagram
post of the week I guess but like here
we go okay you guys ready for the most
[ __ ] up Instagram post of the week
here it is this is the comment I'm gonna
just blow this through because this is
just kind of this go super beautiful but
taking time to Rica this is the caption
taking time to reconnect your inner self
is so important sometimes you have to
have space and reflect on your life
without seeing what everyone else is
doing try to focus on yourself your
goals and what really makes your soul
happy always be true to who you are and
be fearless to be who you truly are
because no matter what someone is always
going to have something to say
I mean alright you know okay but
literally seven million people said that
yesterday you not I mean you're not
doing anything new that's the thing the
years there are there there's this thing
that we have in on social media now like
I saw this girl that was like this
Fitness girl that did all
he's like sped up videos that are like
here's a little tasty snack and she's
like cutting up a cucumber and like
pouring lemon on it and it's like and
then she's like winks at the camera and
it's like huh and it's sped up like it's
a [ __ ] like it's sihyoung pitching in
the 40s you know but like those people
are not creators they're not people who
advanced art or the world in any [ __ ]
way let me be very direct you're not I'm
looking right in the camera here you're
not advancing the world in any [ __ ]
way what you've done is and whether it's
conscious or subconscious you've seen
other people do this and think oh that's
what you do to be successful to have
self-worth and then you do what they did
and you're going through the motions but
you are not a creator you are just
somebody who now knows how to make a
snack with cucumbers and lemon and
that's nothing because we all know you
can do that anyway
so if you're on Instagram posting a
picture of yourself and you're saying
your self-worth is this and that and
don't let others judge you you all you
are doing is repeating [ __ ] that you've
said and that other people have said
rather you are not a creator and you
have you have no talent and that's fine
but don't [ __ ] go saying [ __ ] like
this like it matters because it doesn't
coming from you if Kanye West goes out
there and says some [ __ ] it matters
because he's a [ __ ] creator now like
Kanye West or don't but that's what
is you could think he's a piece of [ __ ]
and that's fine but that's what he is
and and this culture that we have now
where oh I've got somehow I've got
eleven thousand followers because people
wallow me because I'm aesthetically
pleasing to the eye
now I'm gonna do this and I'm gonna be a
person just that [ __ ] changes the
world no you're not no you're not dude
it's just like what I was talking about
about how people who are [ __ ] rappers
who rap about the gun first and then get
the [ __ ] gun you're a phony dude be
who you are and then people will find
out you can't [ __ ] get the people
first cuz you have tits or you're a dude
who has great eyebrows and a nice job on
if you're a model be a model and look
there are exceptions like you know I
don't really know what Tyra Banks does
but it seems like she has turned her
thing into a real thing and all that I'm
not talking about Tyra Banks not talking
about Gisele I'm not talking about
actual [ __ ] you know I'm not even
talking about models I'm just talking
about people who I mean there's [ __ ]
guys who are just like who do this who
have [ __ ] 60 followers that are just
like you know keep your inner circle
it's a [ __ ] it's the OC mentality
that I was talking about you're in a
circle is a [ __ ] thing like you're
not saying anything that [ __ ] changes
anything dude
shut the [ __ ] up you don't drool when
you make love
you're a [ __ ] robot I know you know I
say this with no anger dude it's just
come on help us out man we're all dying
dude you see the world out there and
you're talking about [ __ ] cucumbers
try I guess order I don't know maybe you
disagree with what the [ __ ] I'm saying
maybe you disagree what the [ __ ] I'm
saying but and then you got the
followers and I'm not talking about even
Instagram just people who just believe
in you that are like oh yeah man thanks
I really needed this today how lost is
that guy
how loss is that guy that's like I
really needed this inspirational quote
well it's not gasoline you're not a car
if you're reading Instagram quotes to
[ __ ] get it inspired and helpful oh
man I don't I hope you don't have kids
all right I'm gonna [ __ ] do some of
these quote what do you call them what
do you call them Twitter questions right
here are these Instituto Coates Twitter
quotes it Twitter questions here we go
Kevin black Blacky Stone Kevin
Blackistone
at Gator underscore USA change yet gator
you know if you were a UFC fighter what
would your walkout song be and my guess
is Babylon that would actually be pretty
cool to [ __ ] with the [ __ ] and have some
real or like have some Josh Groban [ __ ]
while you're coming out and everyone's
coming out at to like [ __ ] burn down
don't don't don't don't don't don't
don't don't no or someone else coming
out like [ __ ] DMX but then you just
come out and it's just like
you raise me up do [ __ ] higher than
mountains you raise me up and then just
[ __ ] rear naked choke somebody and
then you leave raise me up I would come
out to some [ __ ] like that uh here's a
good question
Evan Smith at Evans underscore myth Wow
I want to burn your house down with that
[ __ ]
Evans underscore myth I don't like when
you can you know somebody's got like
some kind of nickname or does something
cute and you know they've been doing it
for like since they were 12 you know
like bro Evans myth bro look and look at
his first of all we got two guys in the
[ __ ] thing what's the myth who which
one is the guy the the [ __ ] Mattila
ng and one of them like you're not
mythical bro
you're not you're not doesn't know it
and there's no [ __ ] going on here if
you're just some guy Evans myth god
doesn't that sound like a terrible
[ __ ] movie that would come out in
2001 Evans myth starring Ed Burns
starring Ed Burns and Angelina Jolie
Evans myth Laura Linney's in it too
obviously and Don Cheadle Evans myth
[ __ ] Christ's sake
she's gonna die no she won't she just
started living Evans myth in theaters
everywhere no one will go see it how
many [ __ ] movies did they come out
with in 2001 with [ __ ] Thomas Jane
you know Evans myth starring Evan Smith
- starring Thomas Jane obviously
dude I heard Thomas Jane doesn't wear
shoes I I am NOT [ __ ] you I've heard
on account from France
that they've done table reads with him
and he wasn't wearing shoes as a matter
of fact now I remember I was at an event
once what was the event I don't even
remember an event with [ __ ] real big
stars at it
Christian Bale was there okay in one of
his body shapes and someone and and I
saw Thomas Jane and he wasn't wearing
shoes or socks he pulled up in an Aston
Martin got out with no shoes and socks
on and he was wearing a suit bro we're
not close to the beach Thomas Jane were
nourished no shoes and walked around and
I was you know what I was doing
staring because that's what you do when
you see a crazy person he wasn't wearing
[ __ ] shoes or socks walking around a
step on a syringe bro step on a syringe
one time I walked out of jiu-jitsu when
I was [ __ ] like 23 for I this is the
most amis story ever I was stepping I
walked out of jiu-jitsu and I didn't
have my shoes on and I was going to my
car I stepped on something super sharp
and it hurts so bad and I was like ow
but I didn't look at what it was like a
[ __ ] idiot I just figured it was
glass or something and I drove home all
the way to Burbank from Hollywood and
then I started thinking well what if I
stepped on a syringe so I was like [ __ ]
I might have AIDS and I started sweating
and I was like [ __ ] I'll never know I'm
not gonna go I gotta get an AIDS test in
like a month to find out what the [ __ ]
this is or what if it's like gave me
something else sounds like I could drive
all the way back to Hollywood and see if
there's a syringe on the ground and if
there's not a syringe on the ground it
doesn't even mean that it's not a
syringe maybe somebody picked it up and
moved it after that and it really hurt
this was like [ __ ] I gotta go back and
see if there's some kind of
so I drove all the way back to hopefully
find no syringe but then still it could
have been a syringe hopefully find glass
or something and I swear to God I look
on the ground this is hours later and I
see a [ __ ] dead upside down be I was
stung by a bee I stepped on a bee I
drove all the way back hours later and
there was a dead upside down B that's
the most me story of all time and then
to find it I felt bad I had a little
[ __ ] service for that B low service
would that be
Evans myth Thomas Jane dude Ramona wore
that hat at the Oscars I'll never forget
every few months I would text it I would
I would I would tweet it the picture of
Thomas Jane in that hat and I would
write lest we forget and a picture of
that hat see if it's right Thomas Jane
Oscar's hat I don't know if it'll come
back come up there it is that's the same
hat no there it is under it under it
under it under there it is that's what
he wore that's the [ __ ] one he wore
what the [ __ ] is he doing you got to go
a little nuts to not wear shoes and wear
that hat he's got look no shoe
you have no shoes there Oh what the [ __ ]
are those um anyway uh he's a good actor
he was [ __ ] good in Boogie Nights
right that [ __ ] [ __ ] killed me uh that
[ __ ] why would you wear no shoes to an
event you want to feel the earth you
know that's what he probably wanted yeah
I just like to feel the earth I like to
feel the earth under my feet hey you
know what you can feel the earth under
your feet with your shoes on now but
it's not the same yeah you know it's not
the same your mind your mind broke your
mind was different 20 years ago when it
wasn't broken there it is
Golden Globe Awards that's where it was
the Golden Globe Awards this guy is
wearing a [ __ ] hat
that is just brutal it's brutal
imagine showing up on a tinder date and
the guys got that hat on you probably oh
my god the cigar go back oh my god who
does he think he is
look you got to put that pug on the
video podcast Thomas Jane first of all
has it had on that had on with a feather
in it to really really distill the
[ __ ] Ness and that feather and then
he's got a cigar that looks actually
like a fat [ __ ] if I've ever seen his
cigar look like a fat [ __ ] and then the
tie and then what is he doing dude
is he [ __ ] Eliot Ness hey dude it's
okay to wear all that he's got the vest
on under the suit it's okay to wear that
if you're looking for Al Capone oh and
he's got shoes on of course
no shoes wouldn't go with that [ __ ] look
at the way he's standing one [ __ ]
hand in his pocket like casual like
blood I don't have this out huh well man
I don't have this hat on what man you
think I'm being weird I got my shoes on
he was the Punisher he was the first
Punisher alright let's look at another
question and then we're probably out
what are you doing oh I never listed I
never did the Evans myth one Evans myth
[ __ ] for Christ's sake change that
[ __ ] what do you like to do on your
birthday great good question that's a
good question a very personal nice
question to that maybe the babies want
to know if you if you want to know a
little some about your cult leader right
i-i-i-i I don't like to do [ __ ] I'm a
birthday I like to do a show at The
Comedy Store one time I was in San
Francisco did a show in I did a show in
at Cobbs comedy club and they brought a
kick out onstage for me and that was
really sweet my buddies my buddies did
that weren't you there were you not
there wasn't there one fire one fire for
friendship and yeah so I like to do that
I like to chill I like to get coffee
there's a midday you know what I mean
it's a me day
I don't want to do anything I don't want
to do and it's hard to not know what you
don't want to do right it's hard to
actually not to know that what you don't
want to do because it's hard to not do
[ __ ] for other people because we're not
a lot of us aren't sociopaths what if I
start sociopaths but some of us are and
then we don't we only do what we want to
do and makes us feel bad when we try to
make other people happy because we lose
ourselves in it anyway um oh come on
really my producer is telling me right
now and this is why Wan far this is why
he gets the name he was there in San
Francisco at my par at my birthday and
they brought a cake out and he was there
but he felt he was asleep in the [ __ ]
green room ah is a bad friend don't you
think he'd wake up if everyone was
screaming if five hundred people were
singing happy birthday this guy
in the green room right next to the
[ __ ] everyone screaming have your
birthday or I'm a wrap this up I'm done
listen I want you to go get your merch
your congratulations pod
congratulations podcast merchants give
it to your baby you call your baby cult
members for Christmas will restock in
that [ __ ] this week so keep checking
back a lot of it's out of stock now but
it's getting there so oh wait we got a
new new Elder huh okay let's do that we
have a new out there speaking of elders
speaking of the cult rather Lauren at at
miss Lauren l.y she has created and
continues to update a thing called the
encyclopedia excite encyclopedia Lea
encyclopedia Lea sound like a robot
encyclopedia Lea and secondly appeal
Delia Delia it ends with the Lea anyway
it's a glossary of terms used on the
show so she's constantly updating that
it has things like CUDA by the way I
have a something for you Lauren when you
put the the the the the term she does
things you put the why first the why
isn't the term you could put yeah '
that's the term for you but here's this
is not a term you CUDA and then she
explains what a Kakuta is it's not you
can't say oh you CUDA it's a CUDA is the
term and then you add the Y to it so you
have like you CUDA a person that blindly
goes along with yada yada that's what a
CUDA is not a yucca do understand what
I'm saying yeah
has its own definition so you don't have
to fix it but I'm just letting you know
it's helpful for the new baby new babies
these glossary would just start with
like episode 45 don't know what the [ __ ]
I'm saying when I say it
turn around change it good gunk you know
will di meat will DM you with the
details and get your pin and certificate
that's how you get your pinion if it's
certificate we'll send them to you I'll
get your info will get your info but at
Miss Lauren L that's you can
congratulate her for becoming an elder
at Miss Lauren al thank you very much
for going above and beyond
the cults presence or whatever the [ __ ]
you want to say no not that way but
anyway so uh all right guys listen
movement get 15% off today with free
shipping and free returns by going to
nvm t.com / Congrats square cash you got
a switch
you got a do-it you've been thinking
about it just do it you you're listening
to the show
just do it download the free square cash
app design your cash card get it for iOS
or Android now subscribe to the YouTube
channel please if you're a baby you want
to help me out
download the Chris D'Elia app for iOS or
Android you see behind the scenes
sometimes with one fire
it's got for iOS or Android subscribe
rate and review the show tweet me by
using the handle congrats pod do all
this [ __ ] videos go up on Tuesdays or
Wednesdays upcoming shows at Chris
D'Elia calm San Jose San Diego Riverside
join me on New Year's Winnipeg Calgary
Saskatchewan Pasadena just added chosen
Pasadena California man on fire
incorrigible white male black comic
watch it REE watch it like it I'm doing
some guest stars on some shows coming up
a let you know about that later and
thanks for listening babies and remember
drool during making love thanks guys